look who is zooming in
from the bubble reginald aloysius junior
the third
are you doing dorothy adore my dance i
have
missed you guys what kind of what kind
of room do you got there
a room is it is it a suite
it's a corner room slash
suite okay beautiful view um
look no complaints on my end we get
basketball tonight so
[Music]
i'm rolling with the punches here all
right so you've been quarantined
i've been quarantined i've been tested
twice i've been negative
twice so i get to play tonight i get to
play
analysts so um i'm just excited that
we have competition okay but what's it
like so when you leave your what time do
you leave your room for
a nine o'clock game tonight with the
lakers clippers and what's the protocol
when you leave um
you'll be dressed up i'll have masks on
i'll go downstairs
you'll have a temperature check before
you leave to get on to
um it's like a media shuttle that heads
over to
the facilities um i'll probably leave
around
7 30. it takes about 10 to 15 minutes
on this shuttle um that's composed of
mostly
uh the media we're different from the
players we're housed differently
they're under a green zone we're under
a yellow zone we're not as it's not as
intrusive um so you'll get your
temperature check
you'll head on over to the arena you'll
probably get another temperature check
when you
land everyone has a yellow lanyard
and i'll just go to the green room and
start prepping with uh kevin harlan and
our producers and get ready to uh call
the action
who you've been hanging out with me
myself and i i mean we've been having a
great time
what's funny is my good friend my best
friend my teammate mark jackson we're
all here in the same hotel but
i haven't seen them they it's okay
because we've all been tested and
you know we should be able to but you
know we are in a hot zone here in
florida
and um other than daily runs that i go
on i pretty much come back to my room
order room service
and i do have a beautiful view of
the golf course so but you don't play
golf and i don't play golf which
is like a little bath wing for me but
i have no bike but i do have some santa
cruz sponsorships down here so i'm
trying to get a bike
to get on and ride a little bit but um
mainly i've just been prepping and
staying in my room all right the
main question is have you had the wings
at magic city before
i've never had the wings of magic city
and i'm trying to think
truthfully have i ever been to magic
city now i've been to a few spots
but i'm not sure i've ever been to magic
city
you didn't have the wings there but you
may have been there
i don't think i've ever been to magic
city now i've been to maybe
other places in atlanta just not
magic city so i would be the wrong
person to ask how the wings are
okay but if lou williams is your
teammate
how would you react to that
certainly it's a distraction especially
in these unique environment in the
setting that they're in it's certainly a
distraction
is it a big deal personally to me no
but it's an unwarranted distraction on a
team
that absolutely has a chance to win a
championship
this year so but i probably look at him
cross-eyed yeah but
personally to me it's not a big deal
because he is
so important to our team i probably
would have a conversation
but it's at the end of the day to me
it's not that big of a deal
it's more of a distraction for the other
guys that have to answer the questions
about it
if i gave you lakers or clippers or the
rest of the field to win the title
i would probably take those two teams
okay yeah i would too
but i'm wondering who are we missing out
on aside from
the milwaukee bucks people keep sleeping
on the defending world champs i'm
telling you
toronto in an environment like this with
no home court advantage and you just go
out and play and you've got experience
you've got a team that's been together
and that is juan i know their mind is
kwai leonard
but i think we'll see a a different and
better version of kyle lowry
pascal siekem the all-star has proven
that he is a gamer
you've got size with sergey baka and
mark gasol
and fred van vliet is an unbelievable
player
in shot maker and they are well coached
by nick nurse
no one wants to talk about toronto i
would not be surprised
if they come out the east we're talking
to reggie miller reggie's on the call
tonight
lakers clippers at 9 eastern kevin
harlan will uh do the play-by-play we
were talking about zion williamson game
time decision here
i'm a little surprised about that um is
it a game time decision because
is there an underlying health issue or
because of conditioning
because if if it's conditioning and
you're 18 19 28 years old
get out there and play we have an
opportunity here
and i know they're three and a half
behind uh memphis
memphis has one of the most difficult
schedules in these seating games
and i correct i believe you mentioned
this
uh new orleans has the easiest yeah so
you have an
opportunity to be within that four-game
gap
to have a play-in game possibly but also
to
your alvin gentry and your the pelicans
you're trying to build a foundation
you're trying to build for the future so
are you going to necessarily win a
championship this year no but let's
build
winning habits play off habits let's
play at a high level
intensity level and for me that
includes having zion on the floor so
if he's hurt or injured i can understand
that but if it
if it's coming from a conditioning
standpoint
i heard a you know him comment i could
play 48 minutes if i had to
well let's test that out let's get he
needs to be on the floor playing dan
yeah i just don't know that he missed 12
days when he went home for the family
emergency then came back he's
quarantined so that's 16
days which feels like an eternity for an
athlete
in a season that has been so stop start
stop start
and now you're down 16 games where you
can't get out of your room
even if you were at home you're not
working out the way you would if you
were with your team
i don't know if if he's on a minute's
restriction
i'm fine with that yeah you still have
to play him
right even if it's even if it's five to
six minutes a quarter
play him you know play his way into
shape
because these other guys feed off his
energy and this is a young
scary team new orleans along with
portland i think those two teams are
really going to make a push for that ac
and really push the memphis
memphis grizzlies so it'll be
interesting the lakers and clippers in
their approach to these
games before they get into the playoffs
what would be your approach
for lebron james and kawhi leonard
if you're the lakers clippers milwaukee
toronto and i'll probably even throw
boston in there
there's not a lot for them to play for
in these cdn games so to me
health and finding a rhythm are the two
most important things so
if you're lebron and kawhi um obviously
they
both are going to play tonight along
with paul george and anthony davis who
has you know got
poked in the eye is going to be wearing
goggles tonight find
a rhythm because these eight games are
going to go quick
and they have to hit the ground running
getting ready for the first round so
staying healthy finding a rhythm
cohesion
there's certain players not playing
tonight no sweet lou no mantras harold
no patrick beverly for the clippers and
then no avery bradley and no rondo for
the lakers
so other guys are going to be in the mix
here and finding if you're lebron
and if you're quiet finding rhythm and
balance with some of these other guys
is just as important so i think that's
why they need to play and try to find
some cohesion amongst one another after
lebron
who is the face of the nba
i would probably say james harden
um i would probably throw an up and
coming giannis
because he is he will be the mvp this
year and he'll be back-to-back mvps
i mean he's very personable um
but i think it's a huge gap i think once
kevin durant comes
back a little bit and starts to play um
you could throw steph curry in there but
you know we don't see a lot of
commercials
right now it's a clear-cut favorite that
it's lebron
but who's going to try to grab the
mantle once he starts to
depart from the game and that to me it's
up for grabs
yeah it's a pretty big drop off and i
don't know if it was that big a drop off
with jordan because you still had bird
and magic were still
in the game and you know bird obviously
his talents were diminishing though but
i was it a as big a drop off jordan to
the next guy in the face of the nba as
it is now with lebron and the next guy
well we had shaq shaq was emerging you
had
a.g you know kobe um i don't know if it
was
you know tim duncan um but a worldwide
guy though
because mike was a worldwide guy
i think shaq is worldwide i think kobe
was worldwide
so and and to me i i think
having a two-time mvp uh from greece
that's pretty worldwide to me um
but selling products though is the when
you're i mean
a guy that if you see him on tv you go
oh it's lebron or all that stuff
instantly no and you know their
accomplishments and you can understand
that
but again i think it's up for grabs and
why i think curry and what he has done
in winning championships and mvps and
he's such a great guy
i think that has helped you know be very
personable
to marketers yeah i was just wondering
that that when lebron goes
you know somebody's going to have to
want to be that voice to be that face
and
you and you have to want it you know
jordan was it but i don't know if he
wanted to be it he was just so good and
so popular
lebron has kind of sought this out that
i want to be the spokesperson i want to
be the face of this league
i don't know if the greek freak is able
to do that luca doncic
harden doesn't seem like that's
something that he would aspire to do
steph curry might but he's what 33.
so you know anthony davis is not that
kind of guy
kawhi is not that guy i think i think
now you start you're starting to talk
about
players like zion williams now right but
he
i know are we going to see him i mean
that i think that's the league normally
they like to start marketing you know
some of these younger guys and you
mentioned
luca and zion to be in that category as
well
we had damian lillard on the show last
week and i i asked him who's the mvp and
he said lebron
and i said what's different about lebron
he said
he's just so smart so now you get by at
what point does a player
rely more on his intelligence his
basketball iq
than his physical talent and is lebron
there now
where it's more about the mental than it
is the physical yeah i do think he's
there now though he still
at times shows flashes and glimpses of
the 20 year old uh the 20 year old years
of lebron james
but he's always been this smart you know
he's always been this talented
but i think once you hit that magic age
of 31 32 i think
as an older player i played until i was
38
39 um you start to rely on
some of those life lessons that you
learned in your 20s and i think that's
what lebron
he has that base that's something that
he can revert back to
and though i do agree to uh to a certain
degree
what dame says i think lebron is
the most valuable for his team but in
terms of play
in the mvp i mean the numbers that
giannis has put up the last two years is
something that we've never seen before
and you mix in his length and
athleticism and people say well he plays
in the east and it's
well if i remember he served me right
lebron played in the east
too for a long time and no one held that
against him
so we shouldn't hold because he plays in
the east against giannis as well
yeah i think that they held it against
lebron because then he says all right
i'm going to go west he goes west
they have the best record in the west he
leads the league
in assists and like he's saying all
right uh
you want me to win championships i'll go
to miami and win championships well you
need to go and
you can't be a super team all right i'll
go back to cleveland i'll win a
championship
oh you did it in the east now let go so
he's done everything that people have
asked him to
do and i think people
we love his story the greek freak it was
a story the first year he wanted
it's not a story this year lebron's more
of a story but you're right the greek
freak is the mvp
it's just writers and members of the
media they want to tell a good story
you can't tell the story the greek freak
again we've already heard it
but lebron in reinventing himself in los
angeles
and the kind of player he is that's why
i think he's probably got more attention
than he deserves
and i think this is why you know being
in this bubble situation
again and i can't stress this enough
because we were i was able to go over to
the arena and
we you know kind of did a mock action
call of that
uh houston boston game um a couple days
ago
did you get to shoot in there reg
because i was curious about the back
we're not allowed
we're not allowed on the floor okay we
can't go anywhere near the floor because
remember we can't interact with the
players
the officials or or any game officials
so okay
they're keeping us all separate but
there's there's not a lot of energy in
there
and you as a player have to manufacture
your own energy i know they're piping in
the virtual fans and
they're having all the bells and
whistles but people at home it
is a little different and i will say
this
most of these guys are used to
practicing in an empty arena they all
practice in their home arena when no one
is around so they're somewhat used to it
so but it feels different playing at a
high
level type game with no fans
i want people to understand fans are so
important to our game
because it's that energy that they bring
on certain plays
and something to watch during this next
two
two two and a half months fans they may
not want to
watch the officials because on block
charges on traveling
when you hear the moans of a fan you
know sometimes that sways the officials
you don't have that now so you're gonna
get a true sense
of how officials calls games because
they won't be swayed by the
fans they say they don't but they do
you know you're gonna get a true sense
of the officials
during this experiment i was wondering
about the background
because when when i think of a home
court advantage it's that feeling when
you walk in and you know where you are
on the floor and it just looks
comfortable
nobody has a home court advantage but i
didn't know the way
the basket is and the depth perception
is any of that going to be an issue for
for these teams
it will no not for shooters no and i
believe
of the 22 teams they've all at some
point
there's three arenas that they the games
will be
played at i believe all 22 teams have
had a chance to either practice
or play at each one of these arenas so
they'll be familiar
uh with their surroundings i think the
quality of play will be the same
it's just see players like patrick
beverly and mantras harold
marcus smart alex caruso those guys
that's in their dna and that to me
that's why
they are so valued they will be so
valuable
in a situation like this to rally their
teams when the energy
is a little bit low it's guys like that
you have to have on the bench
to kind of you know get the rest rally
the troops around and get going
what are you going to do the rest of the
day uh we have a
a zoom production meeting everything is
zoomed now baby
we have a zoom production meeting after
this and uh
i'll go get a workout in and i'll do
some more
studying and then again i'll leave at 7
30 heading over to the
arena for lakers clippers
hey this is my shirt i want everyone
take it like this another
and i know you're a big golfer uh
theodore oh
my goodness here we go a walk and talk
here
i'll just tease you a little bit look at
that
[Laughter]
we had we had rudy gobert on yesterday
and i said
did they give you a view of the eiffel
tower at epcot
and so he picked up his uh computer and
took it over to the window and we looked
around he goes nope
that's not here not here not much there
but uh look i gotta give kudos to the
nba
i know they're spending i read somewhere
180 million
on this bubble type campus situation
they've done everything first class and
i was a little apprehensive
again i'm coming from california all the
way here traveling commercial
into a hot zone i know california is a
hot zone but florida is like
volcanic ash hot zone did you think
about not
doing it given you have young ones at
home i thought about that but i also
thought this is my job
right and um you know we talked about it
as a family and
they supported me and i'm here in the
bubble so
the the mba has been first class about
this
and i i truly the people ask what's the
best experience about being in the
bubble and i tell people
being tested twice weekly and knowing
that you're negative to me that's the
that's the best thing about the bubble
is that i know i'm negative
well you feel safer there than outside
the bubble
right i'm inside of it and i i feel safe
so that's the best part we'll talk to
you next week have fun tonight reg we'll
be uh we'll be listening thank you bud
theodore i miss you i miss you my dance
i love you all
let's do the little cabbage patch that's
reggie miller on the call tonight on tnt
at 9 eastern